vineyards dominate the landscape around
Carcassonne in southern France the
Languedoc Roussillon region is the
largest wine growing area in the country
different varieties of grape are able to
flourish in the soil here at domaine du
lac near caucus on you can sample top
quality wines and food
the former vineyard estate is now a
luxury hotel and has been a family
business for generations wine is the
perfect ingredient for star chef
Philippe Dacians recipes this is a dry
Blanc de lis more sparkling wine from
the region I use it as the base for the
sauce in my porcini ravioli dish the
pearls in a sparkling wine gives a dish
creamy consistency which works very well
with the light nutty note contributed by
the porcini mushrooms
Budhan was that salmon on top of a
porcini ravioli in a sparkling wine
sauce is a light starter and today euro
Max has the recipe
first dice the onions and lightly saute
them in olive oil with a little butter
then chop up the porcini x' these are
porcini mushrooms that grew under
chestnut trees and these grew under
Pines because the pine needles often
fall on the mushrooms and they get less
sunlight they're lighter in color you
know chestnuts stand on the other hand
the sun's rays penetrate the foliage so
the mushrooms have a darker color
the mushrooms provide the base for both
the filling and the sauce glaze the
mushrooms and onions with sparkling wine
we reduced the whole thing until the
liquids gone because the mushroom should
completely absorb the wine for the
filling add cream and for the sauce add
stock cream and a bit of butter puree
the mixture and flavor with salt and
pepper
now we had a few drops of nut oil that
brings out the mushroom flavor and the
earthy woody aroma
that's the sauce shouldn't be heated
above 60 degrees Celsius or it'll lose
its nutty taste place the filling on the
pasta dough brush the edges with egg
yolk and carefully seal it it's very
important to ensure that all the air is
pressed out of the ravioli come on
otherwise they burst during cooking
Cecchetti
now turn off the heat
Sommelier honk Cikini is responsible for
the wine selection at domaine du lac
with more than 600 types of wines stored
in the wine cellar the sommelier can
really base his recommendation on the
Preferences of his guests I recommend
this wine with the ravio it's 80%
climatically with clean ash bla
it has a slight mineral note and was
matured in an oak barrel so it also has
a light smoky woody flavor very elegant
very smooth
garnish the ravioli with the porcini
mushrooms that have been sauteed in
butter and the starter for a wintry menu
he's ready for the table and a glass of
ganache to go with it the perfect way to
get into the right mood as the end of
the year approaches
you